so good afternoon everybody and good
morning from Tokyo this is the Thursday
November 14 2019 in our seminar series
on edge computing where we're really
looking at trends not only in the US but
in Asia and I'm very happy to be here in
Tokyo with one of Japan's a
representative one of Japan's most
exciting startups in edge computing so
our speaker today is dr. octo Modi
connemara who is the chief research
officer and also the chief scientific
officer of leap mind and leap mind is a
post series C startup they just closed
their Series C round last month or about
thirty-five million dollars so
congratulations to leap mind for that
and before I ask dr. Khan amaura to
speak I do want to recognize that we
have a couple of visitors with us first
of all I want to say thanks very much to
Kawasaki Heavy Industries for hosting us
here at we work in Tokyo where they've
got a kind of innovation office
cloistered away from their main office
which is an interesting abrasion thank
you very much and also I'd like to
recognize I'm probably not going to move
the camera all the way over to it but
from another one of our member companies
at the u.s. Asia Technology Management
Center we have the chairman of mute
cebiche Research Institute mr. Kelton
ohmori with us and I'm also happy to say
that we have mr. Tai Chi
so got from Japan's national broadcaster
NHK Corporation with us today so we've
got a group here but this is going to be
an interactive conference now because
it's kind of you know being recorded on
the TV and we're I'm going to start
sharing slides once kind of motifs on
begins his presentation
yeah we like to reserve most of the
questions until after he's through with
his prepared remarks but I'm going to
move this over here so that are you
seeing us on the big screen or you see
just a blank page with me SOS on okay
you are great so will this is dr. Kimura
and why don't you start off and I will
get your slides up on your talking is
that okay okay yeah you want to do it
yourself that's the one great and full
screen if you wish while dr. Connie Mora
is doing this I might point out that his
PhD is in informatics from Kyoto
University besides his roles at leap
mind
he's an invited senior scientists at two
of Japan's national research
institutions the a isp advanced
institute for science and tech
industrial science and technology and
scuba japan and also advanced
telecommunications Research Institute
also known as a TR Labs in in Kyoto he's
the author of over 50 papers including
best paper Awards not only from the
Japan neural network society but also
from the I Triple E trust calm so we're
really delighted that you can talk to us
today and tell us more about and okay
the title of my presentation is the mind
direction for at computing ultra what
with computation on embedded devices and
yet they did not member 15 but on your
side it's still 40
okay let me briefly interest our company
leap mind not deep mind it was
established about seven years ago but
actually we started heavily focused on
so-called edge computing or H and I
about the three as a goal and now we
have 85 people and the fund we have
raised so far in total is 60 Korea 46
million including last year's
fundraising and our investors includes
Intel Capital Toyota and others and our
corporate mission is to create
innovative devices with machine learning
and make them available everywhere and
my management includes those people and
I'm here and leave mind has been
featured in the several who I would say
many magazines articles includes both
Jeff and Bloomberg GUI and this is a
brief introduction about our company but
I'd like to emphasize that what is
important is that our company leap mind
exists to achieve this mission to create
innovative device management with
machine learning and make them aware and
I would like to explain what I mean by
for example innovative devices and also
what do I mean I'm saying making them
available everywhere
ok and course about the devices and
leader from Digital Ecosystem and that
this is trend and the forecast of the
number of IOT devices estimated by
Japanese Ministry of Internal Affairs
and communication and you know how the
device is now included many things like
smartphones and some home appliances are
already connected to the Internet and
the more devices like measuring your
electricity on your home will be
replaced with those devices and it is
expected that in the next year that
number of those devices will reach to 40
40 billion and let me just skim over the
slice oh I already explained it for a
few second for each and it is you're
looking at the slide that shows when the
company was established okay great good
and the next one is having our company's
emission with fancy background picture
good ok photos of the management people
and some packages this is the growth of
the number of the IOT devices which is
240 billions in the next year and also
after the next year it is expected that
the number of those devices will
increase more and market size will reach
to a huge amount and the data generated
annually will be 44
the white which is the next unit of exa
and I think it's 10 to the 21st which I
cannot imagine and and by district
distributing those IOT devices what we
like to do and some applications include
intelligent processing of the data
collected by those IOT devices and now I
has been empowered by GPU and also cloud
computing but for some applications
those two key technology to date are not
available for example for GPU it can be
too costly to deploy a muscle even every
IOT device and also even with mobile GPU
like Nvidia is just some nano our
consumption is about 10 watts which is
very small compared to a standard GPU
which consume 200 what however it's
still too much to be deploy for IOT
devices and for the use of the cloud you
need an internet connection and however
for those out the devices start data
transmission of a network is not always
up then and this e shows a market to
segments and for some domains can you
see the other or can you see the cursor
moving yeah okay I think it's she said
yes okay and for some applications like
media entertainment you of course have
continued constant connection to the
Internet to transfer the massive amount
of data or conveying like movies musics
however for other applications like some
factory authorizations and the for
security purposes where even if you have
internet connection you don't want
transmits a few
data and in this case this domain is a
globe power and edge cases and we see a
big market than the knees here and also
we still needed to have more technology
department and the let me share an
interesting study published yesterday oh
no today after your clock and the which
has been published at a New England
Journal of Medicine this is from Apple
heart study investigators and it has
been issue that at Oriole fabrication
which is like by present movie of heart
is very bad for your health
of course however if we can detect at
Oriole publication alley even before you
notice see it then we can prevent
further cardiovascular diseases like
having strokes and natural idea is that
to use available at also non-invasive
non-invasive measurement with SmartWatch
or other way our device to continuously
monitor your heart pulse and they did it
they collect pulse data from about fall
at this number of people and and the
result was remarkable so it four percent
of the people who got irregular pulse
notification from the system apple
heartily mesquita
has worked they actually had a train
fabrication based on ECG data so and
also that many of them were not aware of
the RTC so if this is lesson one the
early example of using Wi-Fi devices and
the user intelligent processing there
and a fortune 3d study I think is not a
real-time application and the false
processing data
but I imagine such application with
wisest widespread over the world and
lead mine who tried to develop key
technologies to achieve this and our
attraction is to use compact neural
networks and also design in their
hardware accelerators and I would try to
skip most of you what is deep learning
and what is revolutionizing about
deployment because you know although you
I assumed already knew this but this is
a typical architecture over neural
networks for image of a coalition and we
would like to run these neural network
models on edge devices but the issue we
needed to resolve is that we needed to
have like small size and low power
consumption Network and we achieve
real-time response because so here we
have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 10 yeah so sorry
about 10 layers of the network
architecture however now deeper networks
includes like more than 100 layers and
it could require many time to give
response and also we don't want to use
network connection to do that so we need
a technology that run and limited our
resources and output very fast response
and should be available even without
network connection okay and that to
achieve that goal we have three key
technologies and that the first one is
low bit and the quantized neural
networks which is to like minimize the
amount of memory and in price you need
to store on those around your networks
and as
counting is hardware designed how do we
accelerators that they are designed to
most efficiently process those quantized
neural networks the third one is a
software stack they were dedicated for
running because I wanted neural networks
on how to absolutely and before going
into some more detail about those
technologies let me give you examples of
the project I did in the past and I
think we have done joint for you to use
several hundreds of companies and those
project includes are driving support and
defection screening drone control
support crap detection danger a lot from
surveillance camera and also
contamination hist action for food or
other materials and let me give you four
specific projects some more on three key
examples and the fourth is with Kawasaki
Heavy Industries and this is a training
site and sometimes small object like an
umbrella is cold in the trained or in
that case the training should not start
because it's dangerous and of course the
current door system has a sensor to
detect if the door is closed or not
however those photos in a small object
that sensor cannot detect the door has
something called SAS door catches
something therefore we did not detect
those small objects coating the train by
the way this train is scuba expressed
Express line and I live in scuba so
today I took this train and the
fortunately enough I didn't get any of
my objects holding the door
[Music]
okay and we automate response is very
important because you know Japanese
people are very punctual
it's except for the timing they finished
work but but after the doors are closed
is only two seconds before the train
departure so we need to do like we're
done processing and transmitting a large
amount of data and in eating is not
quite solution here and that's why we
developed data processing and a deep
line with edge devices and the targeted
device we used was traffic detain nano
that is equipped with Intel cyclone v
SOC and sorry for judgments but this is
a palm-sized device and the power
consumption is about zebra what and so
this chip in the middle is FPGA
so-called ha which we call a hardware
and our hardware accelerator is in this
chip and the Intel cyclone trip yes ok
and this is SOC and also inside it is
arm a 9 civility and this is the
accuracy of the model we have developed
and we run on that small device and if
nothing is coding a door then it's
successfully emitter greenlight and if
fingers or and torille siis yeah here
then it automatically detects something
here and also the time the speed of
finishing those detection is 4 nah it
was one point 2 4 seconds
and I think this was several generation
or the technology and I think our
technology now can achieve more like
faster processing now when you're
calculating that one point to four
seconds a train will have 12 or 16 cars
and two or three doors on a car and so
you're talking about 25 or 26 doors all
closing at the same time yes you can so
really all of that being processed
somewhere yes and distributed okay this
device is expected to be attached to the
door with more smaller and also nicely
in how do you taste yeah yeah but the
alert would be sent through the system
to the train operator yeah only there
are a lot signal yeah submitted yeah
this is the record of the signals are
transmitted over the train which has
already here door closed open signals
and it's having another line of signals
which has a small object a lot okay let
me shift to the next project which he
which is with JAXA JAXA is a Japanese
counterpart of NASA and the Jack's is
responsible for space exploration from
Japan and though and spacecrafts
of course in the space and this is one
of the extreme edge cases and you cannot
transmit a large amount of data and even
if you have bound with this we have a
large latency and the power races are
very limited to because it can only
capture like solar energy or other
battery and we cannot take GPU alone
approaches and and as
as the first task that people in JAXA
considered space air plus selfie project
because you know the practical project
should include automatic navigation
based on imagery sensors to do the multi
track sum or automatic a longing to the
moon or the satellite to the space point
however at the first project we choose
this project and so now is that the
Hayabusa - that is going to the asteroid
and has just turned around the comeback
okay and actually we had what we are
casted model oh I think this is balloon
and this is a model yeah or satellite
but what and what we wanted to do is to
detect which image is the best one I
mean you know here only after a keep the
tip of this asteroid here not good
and the here only the spacecraft is here
but in the middle and the both asteroid
and the spacecraft are nicely in in a
single image so this is the best image
so we would like to submit only this
image because at abandon is probably
this is not enough to send all of them
and so this is after without and what is
shown here in the sport and for not nice
images cause are very low however for
nice for these nice images who is very
high and and now yeah and we did like
space for selfie project with them and
the next product is with NTT DATA and if
you look at the image on the left you
will see many electric wires and I think
in in
you don't see them however in Japan
there are many electric wires on the
skies and we have many typhoons and we
needed to concentrate inspect any
malfunctions on the wire and also I lost
square on my monkey may do something bad
and they considered to use a drone to
automatically traffic our wires however
you can imagine detecting the wire very
intent object from drone is not easy and
also the power resource is very limited
because a large amount of battery is
used for like motor not under they do
not want to use it
Avani so we collaborated and achieved
having a very lightweight and compact
neural network or detecting in wires on
the skies and force and the last project
is with weekend weekend is Japanese one
the largest scientific research
institute under the ministry of
education and science and we applied
michelin technique to physics actually I
have probably to be the experimental
physicist at Rickon and I don't explain
the leader of this project but what is
important is that this dotted line is
the theoretical best trajectory this is
the theoretical best and everybody
worked in that physical sphere and
believe it however by using machine
learning approaches we have discovered
that those colored trajectory that are
very far from the theoretical best
trajectory after they achieve better
result than theoretical best and one of
the reviewers are said that maybe
discovering new physics beyond the
conventional approach and however so
this our paper just reported this
phenomena and we don't know why yet
that this is I think the end always
brain project and let me explain more
about different technology and that air
quantization to low bit and I think many
of you already know that computers
represent numbers using it and typically
we use several tenths of a bits to
represent one number and if we use
32-bit it's it's something we call
voting and we can use 30 bits to
represent number in 14 so called the
floating-point numbers and that this is
single so for single precision every
half precision and the weekend and as we
reduce the number of bits to represent
numbers in computers or numbers in your
network of course we lose precision we
lose accuracy the data representation is
not faithful not not like good
however we imagined if we use only one
beat which essentially says the number
is either 1 or 0 only 2 choices then we
can achieve great reduction of monocytes
and rapid computation and it is not hard
to imagine the sides will be reduced a
lot however so why computation declared
it is that so if we would like to do for
example multiplication with if you have
to get a product of two floating point
numbers you need a dedicated circuit for
that task however if you use if I
exaggerate it is just kind of counting
the number of ones very simple and we do
not need to consume a large number of
sake Frank
this is the basic idea and we did it and
after we used one bit
for neural networks and a two bit for
your NetID activations and by doing so
Bates has only eight zero for one kind
of black and white and activation has
only four selections and the original
image is simplified a lot and we
discovered that even with this extra our
low bit representation we can achieve
something in quite for the size of the
model so this is the comparison of the
size of models for a mobile Natalie to
where is the by Google its size is eight
point five megabytes which is already
great because dykes and people at Google
endeavored to have neural network run on
mobile devices and however by quantizing
to more just one and agility and also by
modifying the network architecture we
achieved 95 99 percent reduction the
model size and the trustee is expected
to decrease
however we developed developed several
techniques to prevent such across a drop
and I think we I would say under a cross
integration is very minimal compared to
compared before colonization and we are
designing our hardware dedicated for
running quantized nor network
so of course you cannot run the neural
network with our subjective design it is
delegated only for contest network but
thanks to not very simple design of the
neural network our hardware is very
small and and Kalama here
we still have CPU but the cpu load is
lower the Gregory thanks
after the up to acceleration accelerator
because we can use the accelerator for
most of the heavy computations for
neural networks and we can reduce the
size of memory on the board and the chip
and also here is reduced activity
productivity with big operations this is
what I have explained about two or three
slides before and attacks to the low bit
representations we do not need to have a
floating-point operation socket and
multiplication addition those are very
simplified and hardware logic is very
simple so that we can achieve very small
20 those a low power consumption then we
can still use a mature Pancho's to
manufacturing processes thicker than the
modern among much of manufacturing
process and still achieve good
performance and unfortunately this
product is not available yet but we have
already released software stuck behind
our technology under the name of the low
oil and this actually is an open-source
software and you can access you can get
the source code from this github
cyclotron guru - below all we can not
get the name without - but you can
access here to get software and after if
you have a fpga board you can run a
contest neural network on your side and
this is what's inside the or but i think
i would try to skip most of them you
have to complete it and also we are
designing processor idly for which is
how to a design follow our assumption
accelerator and I think that concludes
my presentation thank you very much okay
great
well we switch over from the slides I
got a couple of questions that I want to
have first of all you may not know but
you're at least seventh week in our
series on edge computing and in previous
weeks
we bought presentations by people that I
think you may know such as Intel we had
them talk about their chip acceleration
we also so we also had a presentation a
couple weeks ago by tiny ml is weak
Minds involved with Intel with time you
know okay so is is what you're doing
kind of a competitor to the PMO I think
I think people I think they do not wanna
be ok ok so let the eight the point is
the same what you have as a full
software stack you know and my
understanding is they're really looking
at kind of the interface between CPU and
the outside the kind of sensor they're
really looking at sensor networks more
than anything else but you're not
cooperating with them order and in your
idea not necessarily competing with them
yeah I answered no because I think the
power consumption perfect with the print
is I think should should be order of
magnitude different I think ours are
more like small even smaller yeah and I
think the domain is very much different
ok and although I said the performance
of the network after quantitation stays
all the same that is that is just one
example and the weak point about our
technology is that we cannot
quantize any network and for image
classification like object detection in
Sun segmentation for several tasks we
have succeeded in having very likely
than those high performing networks
however it doesn't mean we can quantize
any deep line in with models okay so if
you want to use very complicated you add
a new network model that is not easy to
quantize then you should you can think
of using solutions support from other
companies okay but still we are
expanding the model we can realize so
but I think the mind does not cover all
of them yet okay so about your business
model blue oil is open source yes now if
it's available on github
I guess it's available for free yes and
they can it's licensed and outbox 2.0 ok
and which guarantees to do that the cage
is free even for commercial purposes
right and so that means that leap mind
is earning revenue through point
development projects joint research and
a and these projects like before the to
admit job ok right so do you see that as
the kind of preferred way to continue to
grow for business
yeah I have to say it sounds a lot like
preferred networks kind of a generation
before leave mind which was doing
something some more with industrial
robotics bringing artificial
intelligence into industrial robots do
you see
leap mind expanding into Silicon Valley
so but of coils preferred network yeah
of course we plan to extend our business
worldwide and we would like to have
branches all over the world
ok and we would talk to take necessary
actions to like expand our technique
like so in light of that really one of
the questions that we're asking
everybody in this in our series of
seminars is whether you really see edge
computing developing in sort of
different directions and Asia than it is
in the US I mean for one thing the train
door application is an absolutely great
application for Japan okay so on the
applications you've got some things that
are really obviously appropriate for
some markets more than for others right
but what about the way that people are
solving these problems of lowering power
and increasing speed
you know accelerating the systems so I
don't see a logic wall separating Asia
and the other parts of the world and
core technologies of relief like that
same then what should I add for example
some people in Japan say say that Japan
has a uniqueness in its for example
factory automation now and we should
have a whole Japan structure to develop
or strengthen this already strong stone
part more however I don't agree with
them and I think we don't need to only
unite with Japanese companies Japanese
people and we can cooperate with other
and I extend our technology I think
you'll find a lot of people with global
points of view and Silicon Valley so
thank you why don't we open the floor to
questions and I want to say thanks to
the Kimberly Williams who is our interim
acting assistant director at the u.s. a
new technology management center for
kind of being our point person at
Stanford Kimberly if you call on someone
for a question
what's the power level your target or
level your target to follow them so the
bezel on what Amelia Watts scale okay
okay
next question
how is father G dude doing in Japan in
the United States we have run into
trouble because we can't get spectrum
but what I heard was 5g but Kimberly can
you give me a little more from that yes
how is Japan doing in 5g for the edge in
the United States were running into
trouble because we're having a hard time
getting spectrum so the current proposal
is actually to connect the radios
directly to the cloud I'm sorry I didn't
get okay so this may not be right for
your expertise but the question is about
how is 5g in Japan in the United States
the problem is that there's not spectrum
available for the radio access in 5g and
so there is some suggestion to connect
the IOT devices somehow directly to the
cloud but yeah you've got to have radio
access somehow yeah but I thought if Y
you know but he radios directly to the
plug to connect the 5g radios directly
to the clock I see yeah that's kind of a
I don't know that's sort of a different
technical area that we're dealing with
this week I'm not sure have you been
looking at 5g in Japan
what is 5g before we
though so I think so we have not taken
this summer seriously because we target
or edge devices which does not require
internet or network connection however
for example there are some very low low
frequency network connection a very low
power consumption what you call a PNTR
for what however I think it is a good
combination with I think not 5g but
other more low frequency and low-power
mobile connection network
I think it's a combination with Zeta
devices is very good thing yeah so
today's session is really all about the
processing at the edge itself in the
edge device itself and you see your
sweet spot really in these kind of
relatively extreme cases where you're
not even dealing with a gateway server
or network you're really looking at
individual devices that might be in an
IOT system yep right okay let's do
another question please
so I'm just curious if you have any
American companies you're currently
working with or anything you're looking
to any ideas you have for applications
of leap mind in the US I think we have
talked with several American companies
but do you have any joint project with
US company we've not yet and I and also
however we would like to do cooperate
more with companies in America because I
think our very low power consumption
technology should be of interest
although many people are many companies
there and also the market confound by us
is very very big
also not only business opportunity but
also like doing some advanced to thing
can be easier in the United States for
example in Japan it is prohibited to fly
a drone in many of the urban areas but I
think in the United States I touch kind
of new attempts can be generally
welcomed
okay okay how much of your business is
in the low-power embedded space
augmenting existing sensors versus
installing new systems with new sensors
so can you retrofit to an existing
sensor system or are you really involved
at the stage of developing new sensors
only our new IOT devices on I think our
articles can be combined with like even
with conventional devices but they need
to be upgraded to include our example if
our IP core which is the design of that
chip can be used for conventional
hardware however if you would like to
use it you needed to modify your design
and to include our IP core hardware
design so what you showed with the train
door you showed up a picture of the
system board that had the Intel secret
the Intel FPGA and so I'm guessing what
you would have to do would be to replace
the system board with a system board
that had your software in it
you only need that software I know you
don't have to replace the sensor itself
all you have to do is replace the board
yeah
and also that the board is just one of
the early examples you know and if you
use an FPGA fold then your choice is
even more I
so there are two major FPGA
manufacturers Intel formerly out there
and the and the signings and we have
like hardware design for Xilinx and you
can choose and that can be combined with
any sensors in that regard if I can
follow through I see a real resurgence
in the chip industry of a lot of
development activity to really move away
from FPGAs and torque Asics for specific
applications because you can save power
you can get speed up the system just by
having the loss of flexibility well your
your your approach would still improve
speed and power consumption even if it's
on a set by this yes into a nation yes
the basic design principle of the
hardware is the same you know FPGA and
ASIC and volume matters if you have to
choose ASIC because the initial
production cost is very high for ASIC
yes so if you would like to use many
then you should just choose ASIC and if
we are fully made but you know you can
use FPGA okay thank you nice question
please about to make the machine
learning you know make them available
everywhere give some examples do you
want and do you have specific areas or
sectors that you are particularly
interested in developing partnership
like healthcare or smart home or those
b2b b2c so the company mission we
decided it to be very long-term goal so
it doesn't include any specific domains
however I think we currently are working
with companies
from like Heavy Industries factory
automation automotives
and I think not with the healthcare
companies yet and as a researcher I very
much interested in expanding that that
the boundary of science and that's why I
collaborate with the experimental
physicists they're very much interested
in so-called air technology and that
they deep if they use such modern
technology they can discover more
scientific outcomes and I believe so too
and I like to cooperate with them from
the high side thank you so let me follow
up kind of not so much with which
industries are of interest but in terms
of which AI particular approaches there
are so there's deep learning and deep
reinforcement learning young and
whatever convoluted neural networks and
so forth how does that impact what
you're doing are you working primarily
deep pain deep learning now and do you
see other types of approaches to AI
becoming interesting enough to work with
them as well yeah thanks for asking that
question our Commission says machine
learning not deeply okay because we want
to include other scientific although the
current focus of the company is to have
compact we want party planning models
however it is so if I speak with
companies then I often suggest or
consider to solve real issue I think
this technique not deep learning should
be fastly considered and the shoe the
suit better than using deep learning and
it really depends on the nature of the
problem or or the amount of data they
have or the level of entities or AI
ecology and I think you should start
from using a more basic machine I'm
technology or start from constructing
constructing a data collection platform
you are using me Giovanni okay I kind of
like to pivot off of that question and
ask you to tell us a little bit about
artificial intelligence sort of research
and approaches in Japan in general
because in these days all we hear about
in spoken Valley is Silicon Valley in
China okay right so I think to see that
you you know got your degree and
informatics or coli and you've worked
with national research institutes here
and so forth what's going on with AI in
Japan
okay I would say there are three main
streams in Japan's AI research community
the first one is kind of theoretical
approach transmission line approach
which is led by Professor Musashi
Sugiyama from aversive Tokyo and also he
is a director of Rickon AIP
advanced intelligence project Center and
he strongly believed that theoretical a
mathematical approach should be the one
you should take and he strongly promotes
that direction and after a very
successful his Center publishes many
papers our conference bye guys Emanuel's
and brain strong I think presents over
the world compared to other two streams
and there the second is kind of like a
you know professor hero zero hero yeah
yeah from Osaka University food
developer Geminoid right which is like
looks like a human robot right however I
would say the robotics technology behind
his gemenon robot is not very advanced
because their primary interest is kind
of community approach
yeah and and I remember professor Gama
criticized him by the way and that they
got great random sofa before professor
Sugiyama you know and their presence in
Japan is very big however I think the
robot presents is not some robot however
do you know any like technologies or the
most behind it senior that is because
their interest is cognitive yeah yeah
okay and the third stream is actually I
I was originally from the 33 which is
computational neuroscience and after a
TR P for which I work as a visiting
scientist is the center of computational
neuroscience in Japan and they would
like to rebuild the brain or the human
being by using computational approach
including machine learning and that
their original goal is very practical if
you can develop something that behaves
the same as human then you are not you
succeeded and however unfortunately the
neuroscience knowledge or are saying
this approach is not enough and they are
successful in developing some robots
that will pimp on or other applications
but still far from rebuilding the human
from object approach so yeah and what is
core or what is what brings this boon of
a I it the first approach headed by
professor Geoffrey Hinton and the first
approach headed by professor yes it is
closest to that Professor Sergius is
using fried okay thanks it's very
unusual
very clear and concise overview Wi-Fi
let's have another question from the
audience use only one in two bits does
it increase the yep you mean the number
will I use yeah it though
so sometimes you need to sometimes if
you something you needed to increase the
number of layers to achieve better
performance but it's kind of black magic
there is no general rule what you can do
is to try and they get error and at some
times you succeed and the yes my answer
is yes you needed to adjust the depth of
the network to have the best performance
even without quantization thank you but
that still yields even them but
increasing the number of layers and the
neural net still kneels speeding up if
you can use Genesis the 1 bit number
because I'm no floating-point
yeah because operation for each layer is
is reduce a lot so yeah ok one more
question or something - ok so you
mentioned that is a very nice summary
what's happening in and in academics for
AI in Japan one of the big companies
like Sony and Fujitsu do actually let me
point out that Japan's I think one
unicorn company is this company I
mentioned earlier called preferred
networks that has a greater than 1
billion dollar valuation and they are an
AI company and they're doing large
projects with the big Japanese a lot of
them robotics manufacturers a lot of
them trance
rotation related kind of big data
question problem-solving and so they
actually have a Silicon Valley
subsidiary already yeah yes yeah so I'm
aware of that
what else would you say is exciting here
on the in the commercial side though
sony has released you know at the mcc
which is a GUI platform where you can
build easily your own network and I
think that is very useful and but in
addition to those have for I think
Japanese companies invest to use the
planning and the not only different
measuring techniques a lot in their
opinions and also their customers and I
think in EC is one of the exceptions
because they created two top table data
which is established in Silicon Valley
headed by dr.
fujimaki and free max on was an employee
of NAC but he was alone from NEC to
establish speaking of companies using
that hakuna know this day he has
developed up NAC and I think this is
very unique thing did not see in other
companies just so to bring everybody
into context we featured that project in
our spring series this year okay because
it is really unusual and it is the X in
Silicon Valley is down in the plug and
play center they're trying to find
entrepreneurs and residents to work with
some of their researchers that they
would like to spin out so I think you're
right the big companies are doing things
but they pretty much keep
relatively quiet yeah most of the time
I'm aware of Fujitsu Fujitsu
laboratories of America has a very large
of AI
focus and they often have an advanced
technology forum but is held in various
places in North America every year there
are a number of artificial intelligence
related startup companies that are
interesting we just featuring cinnamon
which is doing kind of IP portfolio
analysis looking at people's
intellectual property and using machine
learnings and see what's really
strategic for a company or an investor
also value next which is doing kind of a
similar thing now they're already public
in Japan so ai is actually moving along
quite well here edge computing impresses
me as the next big thing that's why
we're focusing the series on it this
fall and it's great to see that things
are moving ahead in Japan especially
because I think edge computing combines
a lot of areas in which Japan has
separate strengths there is the
artificial intelligence community
there's the IOT device developers a lot
of the big companies here are developing
really interesting IOT systems and you
have a lot of experience in putting
together quite systems so that has been
something I see as a strength in Japan
of course it's a very international kind
of competitive environment now and I
think that at this point of the series
what I'm seeing is that the edge
computing community has not really
divided into different regional blocks
and I think that's I think that's
probably a positive statement I hope
kind of continues to be international
reactor would you have any comments
you'd like to say about that mm-hmm yes
professor where's the desert it's
Japanese companies does not discuss many
a much information however was ample the
technology developed by profound
networks I think some of it has already
been implemented to factory automation
machines released from tronic one of
profound metals investors and also other
companies also already implement some
sort of AI technology to their project I
believe and also interesting are still
more to deploy a technique yeah there
are problems and yeah I think that come
to think of it is important to remind
everybody that your first project the
train door project was joint with
Kawasaki Heavy Industries and so you
know I really think how it's a key for
making the connections I've been reading
about late mind and to find that one of
our research sponsors has already done
business with you scrappy so anything
from Kawasaki comments okay okay
Kimberly is there anything else on your
side could you say that again please
what are the on the international scale
what are the chip making companies that
specialize in supporting edge devices so
the chips making companies
semiconductor companies that are really
focusing on edge devices who are who are
the players yeah there are many of
Google they first released TPU our
tensor processing unit which is designed
to be used in data centers but later
they released noble our TPU for mobile
use and so Google is not a semiconductor
company but they remain hardware
engineers and design and also
released their own semiconductor
products dedicate for mobile
applications and so speaking of FPGA for
example there what Chinese company or
the T Phi which has already been
acquired by sightings and they their
technique include running neural
networks on FPGA devices and so and I
would say if you imagine any a large
large tech company then about 90%
probability they already invest to
design or produce semiconductor for the
blind why I and also especially for
light AI on edge devices yeah who's
really active there you mentioned Google
with developing ammonia flow chip and
certainly in tell the company how many
featured earlier in our series buddy has
bought my videos which has an
acceleration that was kind of on the
edge during the media yeah yeah so the
chip world is kind of gradually dividing
into the big data center chips and even
inside the data centers you get some
special processing chips that are faster
because there
you know they're smaller and less
flexible in terms of the kinds of things
that they can do and then the chips for
the edge devices and I'm really seeing
growth in the edge to my side of this
which really makes me think that edge
computing is turning into a sort of the
new architecture beyond cloud computing
it used to be you had mainframe
computers with dumb terminals and now
you've got and that went to client and
server and it started out with cloud and
relatively simple edge devices and now
the devices are becoming more and more
intelligent so I think this is about a
good point for us to close off today
we've got four people who are as a
Japanese company do you rely on board
Japanese IC providers a semiconductor
device provides for edge or are you
sourcing outside of Japan - I couldn't
quite hear you we couldn't quite hear
you as a Japanese company do you rely
primarily on Japanese semiconductors for
your edge devices are you sourcing wool
overseas so are most of the chips that
you're putting your software into
Japanese semiconductor companies items
or are you looking at are you using
anybody's chips so we do cooperate with
Japanese like semiconductor design
companies however we of course don't
twist or account activity in data
mystery body in Japan and we already
talked with the companies overseas for
like AI semiconductors and how to
produce it how to implement it
don't need to man so the Johnson ok
thanks and thanks everybody for coming
it's a different experience when we're
on TV instead of in the room it is kind
of nice to see that we can be real-time
interactive from across the Pacific and
bring you you know information about
what's really happening you had this
article that has today's date on it so
yeah it's great we're really delighted
that we can be with all of you and from
everybody here thanks very much
enjoy the refreshments outside and I'll
see you in person again next week when
we have a discussion of augmented
reality so look